the California judge who caused outrage
with a short sentence for a convicted
sex offender plans to speak to reporters
today judge Aaron Persky faces a recall
vote next month after Stanford
University student Brock Turner spent
just three months in jail for three
felony convictions John Blackstone is
outside the courthouse in Palo Alto
California where Persky is fighting to
save his job John good morning good
morning well voters will head to the
polls here on June 5th to decide whether
Judge Aaron Persky will remain on the
bench here today he's making his first
comments since handing down that
controversial verdict that controversial
sentence his latest attempt to convince
an already skeptical public has it time
to release judge Percy Judge Aaron
Persky has just four weeks left to avoid
becoming the first California judge in
86 years kicked off the bench by voters
he became a recall target after he
sentenced ex Stanford University swimmer
Brock Turner to six months in the county
jail for sexually assaulting an
unconscious woman last month the judge
acknowledged the outrage unleashed by
that 2016 sentence the passion is
authentic the end is justified he told
the Mercury News but objected to the way
critics portrayed him so you have to ask
yourself am I really the face of rape
culture there is absolutely no evidence
that he has engaged in misconduct law
professor Margaret Russell is one of 95
legal scholars who issued a statement
saying the mechanism of recall was
designed for and must be limited to
cases where judges are corrupt or
incompetent or exhibit biased
none of these criteria applies to judge
Persky Russell also leads a group
supporting Judge Persky we spoke to her
last August recalling him would really
be a violation of what we want in
California which is Independence of the
judiciary threatens the rule of law it
threatens the rule of law michelle
dauber who spearheads the recall effort
disagrees this is a democracy and the
judges in California under our
Constitution are accountable to the
voters they
serve dobbert incites three other cases
with the judge issued favorable rulings
to college athletes accused of sex
crimes and violence against women judge
Persky is shown over and over again that
he has poor judgment and we believe they
will vote him out on june 5th a majority
of people here in Santa Clara County
appear to agree with Dawber in March a
poll by CBS San Francisco station KPIX
found that 56% of voters wanted judge
Persky recalled just 29 percent said
they wanted him to remain on the bench
John not good numbers for the judge
thank you John